some of you may not be strong enough
to make it through this video but here
you are strength isn't just measured in
muscle no
it's measuring will raw willpower
lets you see past the lies and into the
heart of the truth
it's not easy to stare truth in the face
and not flinch
oh it's a good bag be warned
you're in this now and you have to see
this through to the end
what i'm going to reveal to you is going
to shake the foundations of your entire
existence
and maybe future generations beyond that
that are affected
by the possible changes to your dna that
this will cause
takis can't sue me for that can they
there is no
evidence that suggests that
takis will change your dna
there's no evidence none you can't find
any that i know of
oh mama so show that you're going to be
a part of this
until the end click the like button
because people are spamming the dislike
button just to try to hide the truth
to try to obfuscate it that's the right
word
you must set the truth free john
prove it to me prove it to each other
but more importantly
prove it to yourself today i'm going to
be reviewing every single flavor
of takis i have what is scientifically
known as every single flavor of takis
this is a terrible angle to see this
lixie and zoom in on that
not really a lot of detail i much like a
baby
have no object permanence so if the
flavor that
technically exists isn't in this room
with me right now i don't know it exists
and therefore it doesn't exist to me and
because all of reality
is based on perspective and everything
is relative
my existence proves that those other
flavors that may not be here don't exist
it's simple logic there is nothing weird
about the way that i eat takis
and eat is also a very strange word has
a lot of different meanings you know
the dictionary is kind of the jury's out
on the definition of eating but i
eat them like this do you eat super do
you drink soup
nobody knows the three bears with their
porridge
one was too hot one was too cold one was
just right but according to who
nobody knows cause goldilocks is dead
they hate her
anyway this is not about that takis
i'm a big fan i'm a big fan but i
already know what you're thinking and i
already thought of it they're not going
to sponsor me
i've already asked because i didn't ask
to be paid in
money i asked to be paid in powder
and they said no so
[Music]
didn't work out but i'm gonna review it
anyway because i still enjoy them
i like the powder so i do have some
critical things to say about takis's
um production pipeline
there's a little bit of an inconsistency
issue with takis
from bag to bag i started out takis and
i was lucky enough that my first time
getting takis
that the individual taki were soaked
beyond recognition under a layer of
delicious powder like
just pure salt spice and msg
but it's like a lottery depending on
what bag you get
you may not get the same spice
experience
that i got on my first thing it's kind
of
like drugs i've been chasing that first
high that i got
when i got the first bag and now it this
seems really bad but trust me
i know what i'm talking about
like seeing do i know what i'm talking
about anyway it's not the point
i only have eaten fuego
fuego is the purple bag it's it's the
only bag that i saw for a long time
uh but there are other flavors of takis
that are not fuego
fuego is my favorite so far i've only
had one other
but there's a bunch ah one two three
four
five six seven seven eight seven
eight this makes eight also i'm gonna
show you guys a whole new world
and this is where it's very important
that we're all in this together if you
clicked on this video it's already too
late you're a part of this this is in
your watch history and i've made a deal
with youtube that this particular video
cannot be purged
from your watch history no matter what
it's going to remain on your account
till the end of time and when youtube
dies
that's when time dies we all know this i
will cease to exist
and from my perspective because
everything is relative uh everything's
gone
it's just an egotistical way of thinking
about things it's not actually true
anyway
so the thing about takis and fuego
is that it has just the right amount of
kick right
whoo
what's some good
it's like eating shrimp right i don't
eat shrimp but i think
you suck the shrimp out of it and you
throw the rest of the shrimp away
right or like a clam you don't eat the
shell of the clam
i don't need this shell of the takis and
this this happens to be a pretty good
bag i'd say this bag is above average
you can actually see
almost the entirety of each chip is
covered
in powder you get a kind of chip that is
just
more powder than chip that's ideal this
bag is above average but when i tell you
this bag is like 30
of the maximum amount of powder that
i've seen in different bags
this is like a 220 of the
week bags that i've seen i've seen bags
that when i opened them
i got depressed instantly all joy flew
out of my life because i looked at the
chip
and it was empty it looked like this and
i think that's what happened
someone got to the powder before i did i
think there's a whole operation to suck
the powder right out of these
takis won't give it themselves but i
want it and i will find it
because as they said on dune the spice
must flow i've never seen dune the
spiciness level is like a
bit of a six it's a good one it's above
average spice it's a good kick
compared to that chip that i ate on some
mysterious channel that doesn't exist
and never did exist
much like this video won't ever leave
you that video
never even occurred if that was a ten
this is a six
good spice but the flavor that's really
what we're getting into here the flavor
is something that's just
i can't even match on anything else that
i've ever tried i've tried different
like
spicy powders people say like there's a
seasoning that you can get
that is pretty good it's not the same
and i think
it's due to the msg the ms
[Applause]
i also cut them like this because it's
easier to access and then you can
identify the ones with more powder
and that way you lose minimal amount of
powder getting on your hands and you can
just make sure most of the powder gets
in your mouth
i open like this so it's like a built-in
tray doesn't make good for showing the
ingredients
but zoom
there's monosodium glutamate which is
another entire conversation to have
there's a big stigma about monosodium
glutabace but apparently there's no
actual research that said it's bad for
you in any way
in fact it turns out to be a pretty good
flavor enhancer but i'm not a food
doctor
i don't even know what a food doctor is
do they exist
but this has msg in it unless i'm
mistaken because i didn't
look at it myself just now
like seeing them i'm right okay good
the only problem is with the amount of
salt that you're taking in
you got to make sure you get enough
water you got to hydrate when you're
doing this because either
even one of these is probably not good
for you
but i like salt and i like these
[Music]
looks like got a sweetness to it it's a
spice this happens to be a very good bag
i am very happy if i got this my
happiness meter would go up as opposed
to being extremely depressed
my entire emotional state depends on the
interior of these bags it's like
schrodinger's takis
my fate is sealed in the bag and i do
not know
until i open it but i have found ways to
try to circumvent that
i kind of feel and if i feel more powder
at the bottom i can kind of be inclined
that it's going to be that
also there are certain types of bags
that are made certain ways you'll see
that this one has ridges on the top of
it there's some bags that have
flat tops and you can kind of judge
where that one was produced because i'm
pretty sure that there are three
different takis factories
in the us i've never actually done any
physical research on this i've never
seen them myself i've just done
anecdotal research from the takis bags
that i have
and there seems to be one that does
lower with different
type of chip like the actual tortilla is
a little thinner
and a little smaller the volume has
probably decreased like a by about 40
and the powder ratio is way down there's
this one which is good because it's a
pretty
average and streamlined process of the
amount of powder
and the amount of chip tortilla chips
actually carry a lot of suckability so
you can suck the powder out of them
you know i like that i don't like it
when it's hiding in the crevices
and then there's another one that is
just chaos factory i want to be in that
factory i want my life to be that
factory because the people working there
are just as insane as i am they destroy
every chip with bag
the entire bag is like 30
powder in the bottom of it and it's all
crumbs and there are some weird chips
that are just like
burnt black triangles in them that is
the gold mine of takis those
are the absolute pinnacles i went on a
bit of a tangent there i'm gonna move on
this particular bag nine out of ten
maybe like eight and a half just because
i know the scope of how good it could be
but this is a good one
so from now on we're going to look at
the new flavors let's kick it up another
notch
i can't see over the effects this is
nitro
oh hey male hey hey ups guy
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this is nitrogen uh digitally make my
hair blow back in the wind
okay this is nitro i actually have had
this if you want to talk about spice
this was a six
this is way i i'll taste it first and
then i'll give numbers why would i know
beforehand
well this is sad
it's not it's not the color differences
that you can tell
you can tell that it's less powder this
is what i mean this is why
my emotions are all over the place look
you can see the surface of the chip
through it the only time you can see the
surface of the chip through this one
is where it's been like exposed
underneath because it's like a double
wrap chip and there was some flaw in the
process this is
god that's sad
fine anyway this is gonna be
sad but i'm gonna test out the flavor of
it because that's what i'm here for
nitro
i can't even taste the difference
because there's not enough powder to be
able to discern it
i have another bag here let's see if
this one's any better
i buy them in twos and i go to different
stores and i try to pick one from there
one from there and when i know
a store has the golden bags i buy out
their entire stock
god damn everything
it's the same same god damn
we got a good here's a decent one
okay so definitely that one's spicier
but because there's less
actual quantity this would be spicier
just because there's more powder here
but this one is the only problem with
this one is i don't like the flavor too
much the great thing about this is it's
perfectly balanced between the spice and
the lime
this one is habanero i don't really like
the flavor of habanero i know a lot of
people do
but most people just use habanero
because it it has a lot of
kick to it it's not like ghost pepper
levels but it's got a real punch to it
and they use it for the spice i really
don't like the flavor as much though and
the spice isn't even worth it because
the spice isn't all that much different
than that one because that spice
kicks you harder just from the quantity
i'm gonna find the one with the most
powder i can
versus one i just grabbed here and you
can see there's
it's not even close it's not even close
it's not even close
it's a disappointment across the board
this particular bag i'm only gonna give
like a three and a half
okay so now we've gotten out of the
territory where i've ever had any of
these before
these are all new the experiences will
be new my reviews will be just as subpar
as anything else in fact even more so
that's what you subscribed for right
what did i say and i am officially
declaring that i am now the talkies
review channel
i know that john cena was in a
commercial for takis the other day
or the other year whatever one it was
there's no way that guy likes more
takis more than me maybe he likes the
chip he can eat my chips after i suck
the good stuff off of him
okay we got wild like wild west
wild spicy buffalo i can't even tell
am i sad am i happy am i sad am i happy
i can't tell
okay i think i think i'm kind of happy
because it's an illusion right
the color of the powder is very close to
the natural color of the chip whenever
they pull the chips off the chip tree
i'm assuming that's just the color that
it comes as
uh much like spaghetti from the tree
powder you know is actually oranges
like spicy buffalo wings you know stuff
like that so
i can't really smell anything the powder
is kind of stuck to it
[Music]
weird brainwave for some reason my
tastebuds are telling me that's similar
to this
tokbokki that i had in korea which is
spicy rice cake
but not good because i'm not expecting
that as far as spicy buffalo con
is concerned that nothing like that i
don't taste any buffalo from that maybe
i do but maybe i just don't know what
buffalo tastes like but i've had a few
wings in my life
i'll probably review a few wings in my
life maybe who knows
if they pay me money i'll review
whatever they want my review series has
never been paid for its services
i just want to point that out it's a
little tragic
anyway i uh two i really i don't i would
never eat this and i would not want to
suck this so i won't
those probably good crushed up and like
used as a bread crumb
i bet if i breadcrumb real wings with
that
good idea i won't remember it crunchy
fajitas
which isn't really a flavor it's a
description i don't know what flavor is
crunchy fajitas it's another one of
these illusions because you can't tell
because of the base color but i
whatever crunchy fajitas is place your
bets now in the comments as to what you
think the flavor of crunchy fajitas
is or will be and my reactions the
winners
will get shamed the losers will get
banished you can abstain you have to
i guess i guess
i'm getting like you know a hint of
fajitas
i feel like i'm standing outside of a
mexican restaurant
and there's a fan that is blowing air
out of the restaurant into my mouth
whoever predicted that that was my
response
congratulations everyone shame them
shame them no shame them fast and shame
them quick and then shame yourself
but not good i wouldn't call that good
i'd rather just have
like frozen fajitas that i put in the
oven or something like that there's very
little
actual flavor here there's like no
flavor nothing's actually happening here
there's like essentially zero in this
bag
sorry there are people walking and
they're looking at me i'm not crazy
why are you even here why do you exist
you go on the floor now
floor of shame what if i just mash them
up re-wet them
turn them into tortillas re-fry them and
then make fajitas out of them that's
what i'll do so we got this
other bag guacamole whack-a-mole look at
the ridge on this bad boy that is a deep
v see this is a piddly v this is a deep
v good
powder
oh my god that looks horrible that looks
the worst that looks
so unappealing uh i got no words for
this one so i'll just let taste be the
judge
that wasn't a finish spit that was just
this is like shrek's turds i don't know
what
i i i i i don't know i have no idea
i what is not guacamole maybe these are
different if i
bite them
oh it's just it's worse because i get
the terrible tortilla in there
i hate that i'm not going to reuse that
for anything
good oh god
i hope you're still with me everybody
you made a promise at the beginning of
this
you were going to show me how strong you
were and if you abandoned this
halfway through or three quarters of the
way through wherever we are
you'll never let it down sticks
sticks it's fuego in stick point
oh weird i don't know why
they wouldn't just stick with uh stick
with uh
normal fuego uh because now it's it's
like
it's like those like rice noodles that
you get sometimes in the bed of an
appetizer at some
cheesecake factory or something like
that i guess they're trying to get me to
eat the
actual tortilla
it's a disappointment number one i don't
like the tortilla number two
there's literally less surface area per
chip to have
powder there's no ridges there's no
places to
caress with your tongue to try to
cultivate out a little bit more spice
cokes if you will i can't seduce this
with my tongue
get out there you don't belong there
[Music]
i'm happy again i'm happy again i'm
happy again all right so
you might think that we must be done
right we must have run the full gambit
of every possible flavor
shut up you're wrong i'm sorry i didn't
mean to yell you
also the mailman's here so i gotta look
nice
i'm nice
[Music]
thank you i don't know why
i always record these when mail comes
it's not a choice i'm not doing it on
purpose it just happens that way
explosion
it's an explosion of flavor boom one two
three four five
explosions of flavor uh it's got cheese
and chili pepper
no lime on this one apparently but it's
an explosion of flavor
explosion
best before december 2020
oh no oh no
oh no oh no am i gonna die
oh no oh
oh no
that's probably fine oh these look fun
look at that is this gonna be like
cheetos like like spicy cheetos
oh that tastes like someone took
the powdered cheese in a kraft mac and
cheese box
and dumped it in a bag
now let's all be clear this is expired
that might be why it's bad but i doubt
that it changed the flavor that much
okay are we done here are we done
no we're not done we got zombie
the flavor that's back from the dead put
some fog in
get some spooky music there's a wolf
howling he says homie
it's a scary night you're hungry you got
nowhere else to turn
you go into a convenience store the bell
rings with a groan
as you walk through the door the sliding
automatic doors creak
whistle in weird ways you hear a cackle
of laughter from the back row where the
booze is kept
and then you'll see it in front of you
zombie flavor
you look in your pocket you only have 92
cents and it just so happens
that halloween ended a few months ago
and these expired chips are on sale
clearance it's time to get a deal
and time to fill that belly of yours
with
pure evil uh they're green
these are worryingly green like the
guacamole was sad green
this is concerningly green it says
habanero and cucumber
that sounds like it wouldn't be so bad i
have said that many times tonight
it's day but i've said that many times
and it's not
worked out too well your bottoms up
you know what that is because the other
one that was nitro
that was habanero this is better the
cucumber works
better with habanero than lime did it's
not that lime and habanero is bad no
that's a great combination but for some
reason in that chip and powder
that didn't work as well this works the
flavor is
actually pretty good they're working
with each other and it they might still
have some lime in here i can't tell but
i
i taste definitely the cucumber and i
definitely feel the habanero but the
the the the flavor
i remember that i'm into that i'm into
that that's good i did not expect that
to be good at all it's refreshing
i'm going to keep that over here because
that's quite good all right
so we've reached the end of the road
it's been a long day of trying takis a
long day of attempting different flavors
shut up we're not done
got him idiot heat
like sonic the hedgehog if he's in
here let's see it cut out everything
that i just did
there's no illustration of what this
flavor might be all i know is that it's
blue that was green this is blue
once again concerningly
blue thought provokingly blue right
like something's wrong here but
it's food anyway
that's a decent one
not much flavor it's not bad it's not
what i would call bad flavor it's just
not much of it probably the all the
chemicals to make it dyed blue
uh are burning off my taste buds on
contact so my entire inside of my mouth
is
melting or not don't sue me takis pay me
in spies give me a 55 gallon
thing of this in conclusion
this is the best the original flavor is
the best
i have tried all of these and to be
perfectly honest
a lot of them aren't very good to me
anyway and and i imagine that a lot of
people's first introductions to takis is
going to be fuego because that's the bag
that i always saw so i imagine it's the
bag that everyone always saw
not everyone but you know most people
always saw so
fuego is my favorite flavor but
surprisingly zombie
that i would never have expected is
second place the if
if the habanero one had a lot more power
on it
and i was in the mood to really destroy
myself with spice
i would like that that that's third
place everything else is tied for bottom
and with that so ends my review of takis
and you've made it congratulations
you've made it to the end i'm proud of
you
you've done it congratulate yourselves
and congratulate each other and you know
what your reward is
your reward for making it so far is that
you get to watch me finish the rest of
this bag
with uninterrupted eye contact i'll make
sure
the editors i'll make sure
that lixian doesn't stop the video at
any point
to interrupt this moment of connection
that we are going to share
because we are one and the same
you and i we have so much in common
150 more to go
you